what I want you to help me with is to
have a look quickly at where you created
constructed your tables for each of the
three that I gave you you go look at
this table and for this first one which
was made up of triangles just adding
onto each other
what were the three numbers you had for
the number of matchsticks in these
shapes what was the first number you can
even just see it it was three and then
Sikhs and then and then you worked out
the next one would be twelve and then 15
and so on right so in each case we
determined that the number of
matchsticks was the shape number
multiplied by three so I can write that
simply as three s fantastic we're a
little bit difficult was your first
number for this shape eight and then
that was followed by 14 and then 20 and
then 26 was what you probably calculated
okay now what I hope you noticed was and
I'm gonna highlight it for you so just
look up for a second because I want you
to see me actually drawing this off when
you said okay for my number of
matchsticks young right I hope you
noticed that what was crucial was the
common difference between each of the
terms here you grew by three every time
that's why we had three times s in this
case you're going by what are you
growing by it six isn't it and you can
see watch me drawing here's one two
three four five six new matchsticks that
you had to add to turn from shape 1 to
shape 2 so that's why I hope you worked
out the rule was the 6s M equals 6 s
plus 2 because if you don't have that
plus 2 here all of your numbers are off
by the wrong amount
who's written down their numbers for
this one I mean we've got three what's
the next one sir then that's that's a
weird-looking three what's the next one
twelve and then did anyone work out what
the next one would be eighteen dot dot
dot now the issue here and the reason
why I didn't have you create the rule
for this one if I like with these right
where you've got a common difference
every time three or six the difference
here keeps changing for the difference
in shape to in shape three five sir
hold on these guys are going popping up
and up right now we do have maths
what's going when we were asked the
number shapes and M the number of match
if you draw these on a graph which is
what we're going to be moving into um
you wouldn't get a straight line all
these linear pattern something we're
gonna explore mostly early next week but
I wanted to give you a bit of a teaser
for why we introduced this unusual word
some of you have finished doing your
extra shape somebody we're gonna be
checking that first thing to finish your
new shapes we want to see what the
patterns look like and then see what the
rule is that you come up for each one
the last one because you know that's a
bit freaky okay I've said it again sorry
so we'd love you to have an extra one
that's simple like this an extra one
that's a bit trickier it's modified like
this and then an extra one that it's
difficult to come up with a rule for
even though you who can tell me what the
next shape looks like it's hard to
describe the algebra for at least a bit
trickier okay so you made three patterns
on